16th anniversary yesterday of the
premiere of the american version of the
office there is an awesome
english version of the office as well
although frankly you may need subtitles
if you're an american viewer to
understand exactly what they're saying
on the english version of the office
sometimes it's a little bit hard to
follow in that respect they tried do
they think we did they have that problem
with us sometimes i wonder like where
they're going like that's not english we
invented the language and i don't know
what that well yes with you for entirely
different reasons yeah accent that's for
sure
taking me out of the equation because
you're right like i watch like uh yeah
we'll we'll pull that next week i'd like
to know that from our our england
watchers or uk watchers if they because
there are shows you're right in in
england like the crown or things like
that that i watch and i'm like wait what
what the hell did she just say i don't
understand that
one of the things that i enjoy about the
topics that we trip over that instantly
become poll questions on your twitter
page that i then retweet the people who
aren't watching the show and there are
many of them they're wondering what in
the hell is wrong with us
we're asking these random bizarre
questions in a morning it's like folks
these are all coming from you know our
organic discussions during pft live so
today's draft
nfl people you would want to be
your boss and uh i've got some
possibilities here and i'm not quite
sure how this is going to go chris
you've got a trivia question for me not
the first pick matters at all today no
it's our ritual go ahead ask me the
question we'll see if i get the first
pick okay
when michael fires devin
instead of creed in the second season of
the office what does devin do to
michael's car i don't know this like
i've told you oh i know this oh i know
this i know i've seen it recently he
busts a pumpkin all over it he busts the
pumpkin all over it wow way to go you're
really yeah you're has this supplanted
seinfeld as your new seinfeld now to
where you're watching this and like
you're gonna know every episode here
soon it's equal it's equal it's equal i
gotta get on i gotta get on the office i
really do
my wife and i have been watching the
office just kind of as filler like if we
watch a movie and we still got time
before it's time to go to bed we'll
watch an episode of the office and we're
working our way through it on peacock
and you know season three the superfan
cuts extended episodes if you've seen
them all before
you haven't seen them at least for
season three and my understanding is
eventually other seasons will have these
extended cuts because there's a lot more
that they shot that didn't fit into a
half hour show so uh there's our we've
done our corporate duty now we can move
on to the draft although the entire
draft is an extension of our corporate
duty to hype the office first pick for
me
oh good god
uh i gotta go jerry jones just because
of the boat two two reasons
i i assume i would get on the yacht at
some point and that would be reason
enough to work with jerry jones
second of all just being around him
you're gonna get smarter from a business
standpoint i think bill parcells in his
autobiography talks about
all the investments that he made
at the advice of jerry jones the things
he learned from being around jerry jones
from a business standpoint i mean the
guy is a brilliant business person he's
become kind of a caricature over the
last 32 years and that's what happens
when you're just front and center
soaking up attention looking for
publicity for your football team you are
going to have that reaction he doesn't
care he's selling the nfl he's selling
the cowboys he's selling himself and
he's made billions i think i would like
to learn a little bit about business
being around jerry jones i i hear you
there i mean there's there's a lot of
good and there's a reason a lot of his
ex-players are in love with them and as
loyal as they can be because because of
the way he treats you so i i hear you
and you're right there's probably a lot
we could learn from from a lot of
different angles that he's attacked life
um
and also also good places to find wine
cheap gas stations etc oh yeah obviously
i'm sure he's got all the tricks don't
you worry he knows how to drill for oil
fine deals do it all he knows how to do
it all all right i think my first pick
i'm gonna go with the super bowl head
coach i'm gonna go with bruce arians i
mean i just feel like we're a match made
in heaven that's why he likes to curse
i like to curse he likes to retox i like
to read talks i just think it would be
too much fun you know again he's a
jersey guy so i think there's a part of
me there that loves that aspect of him
but anything i've ever heard you know
about him and just being around him a
few times really quick at the combine
that's all i really know i just i love
being around him i do i could see why
people want to work for him and do all
that like here
here's the here's the great thing he
said to me at the last combine right
he goes
i go i said something like hey you still
got pictures nick of me up in the
facility and he looked at me and he went
yeah in the training room
that was awesome i was like that's my
kind of guy right there you know yeah i
almost died but you put me in the
training room fine
he's on my list too yeah and the big
difference between him and you
with you there's detox
with him it's just always it's all right
there's never a detox
one of one of his great lines is rum and
coke is the drink that he drinks when
he's not drinking um
okay you took him off my list uh
i'm gonna go jim irsay for one very
important reason i assume that jim irsay
would not have a problem with me going
in and messing around with all of his
expensive musical instruments when he's
not in the office because he's got a
museum of expensive musical instruments
and you know you go strum on someone's
guitar jimi hendrix his guitar and go
play john lennon's piano that would be
kind of cool and also i mean look
jim irsay seems like at his core a good
guy yeah he would be a fun guy to work
with a fun guy to be around right and
you know he i even though sometimes the
confidence in the team is a little bit
unwarranted i'd rather be around
somebody who's inherently optimistic
than somebody who's inherently
pessimistic like i usually i'm with you
and he's always trying to support the
team and spend money and do those type
of things you know you know he he'd
probably throw a few drinks back with
you i mean we know he likes to party a
little bit and hey i mean the guy
has his own
glassed in case
in the suite in indianapolis so he could
smoke cigarettes while he watches the
game i mean that just is that the baller
boss move of all time that is like
unbelievable thing so uh that so
basically it's it's a cigarette version
of the pope mobile it really is i've
seen it you know being in the stadium
there before on that level and i was
like what is that and they're like oh
that's cersei's box and i was like holy
crap he's got a whole in you know
filtration system and this whole little
thing just for him so that's that's when
you know you're a baller um okay my next
one i think i'm gonna go with uh i'm
gonna go with andy reed
you know i just andy reed is just it's
it's too
too good of a guy just
you know
easy to get along with
you know make jokes yeah he loves
football he empowers his players to give
him ideas he's got all these crazy you
know trick plays and things they have
fun with i just look at him and think
that would be great to play for him
because of the way he kind of approaches
work on a day-to-day basis let alone
i mean come on now
you know if you get a case of the
munchies there's nobody you'd rather
hang out with andy reid for me
i mean he's gonna have great food great
catering all that he should have all the
spots all of them what
i don't know he may not share he might
not share but he's got a lot of money so
he can buy me some too or you know we'll
do it together but either way i uh i
love me some andy reid and just the way
he kind of carries himself and treats
people if i was a snarky jerk
the the my nephew
my next pick would be jack easterby
because my argument would be he has no
idea what he's doing so he would have no
idea whether or not i know what i'm
doing so the bar would be low but that's
not my pick because that's not the way i
am
pete carroll is my pick because that guy
has so much natural energy and you know
as human beings you feed off of that
when you're around people who are just
positive and up all the time and and and
that's that's you know on on a day when
you're kind of dragging a little bit
you're around something like that and
he's got that high energy that
that's important you need to find a way
to muster your own energy and sometimes
if you're around somebody who naturally
has that energy you don't need to to
start your own lawnmower he's going to
start it for you yeah i i i hear you
there
he was on my list just because of that
energy and the way he is and you know
bounces around and does all those type
of things
uh i i i get that all the way
he trans the transformation of pete
carroll
from guy who isn't in the stadium and
isn't around football to guy who is
around football continues to amaze me
i'm telling you when you see him away
from football he's like a mob boss who's
on trial and is trying to make it look
like he's old and decrepit so they
wouldn't think he's a mob boss and then
as soon as it's go time he's jumping
around bouncing around throwing
footballs running around it's amazing to
see that transformation no it is you're
right uh there it is it's amazing that
way and he's always like that my last
pick though i'm gonna go with sean
payton sean payton to me johnny psycho
scientist in the lab all the time
inventing these crazy plays you know
swears cusses real football guy and i
feel like there's a you can make a
connection on a human level too where
it's not always just coach talk so i
like sean payton a lot
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports